It's do sports,
you know,
they've been involved in athletics in some form,
whether it's martial arts or gymnastics since they were little.
They do things that are difficult.
We do stuff as a family that are difficult.
We do like escape rooms.
We play games,
we do things that are hard.
I don't let them win.
Yeah.
I mean,
my,
my little one,
I let her win sometimes and stuff.
Like we play carnival games against each other or something like that.
I'll let it,
carnival games.
Yeah.
Like go to like a circus circus.
Like when I was in Vegas,
I was in Vegas for this thing that my daughter was doing.
So I took my youngest daughter circus circus playing these carnival games.
Okay.
I let her beat me a bunch of times.
Shh.
Don't tell her.
But that's,
we're having fun,
laughing,
being silly,
talking trash to each other too.
Yes.
She high fives me and stuff.
It's fun.
But uh,
I,
I think there's value in learning that it sucks to lose because that makes you
reassess like what you did that the other person did better and how do I beat
them?
Yeah.
It's like,
well,
we're talking about weed,
but weed making you nervous and makes you paranoid.
Like I like that.
What I like is,
look,
I'm entirely too successful.
I,
I like,
I like to feel vulnerable.
I think this is,
it's a lot of good to that,
you know,
like legitimately I lot,
I liked that feeling because it makes me,
um,
it makes me more connected.
It makes me more humble.
What do you mean you're too successful?
Well,
you can only have so much success in this life for you start thinking that
you're different than other people.
You know,
you're thinking that you're something special.
No,
he,
look,
if you're on a path,
right?
If everybody's on a path and you start off here and then x amount of years later
your way away,
you could start thinking,
oh,
I'm better than all those motherfuckers,
but you're not,
you're just,
you just have been on this path longer and you haven't fallen off of it.
You've figured out what you need to do to stay on that path.
We know a lot of people that were on the path at one time in their career and
then something happened and they lost their enthusiasm or their body wasn't as
healthy or whatever the fuck happened and they dropped off.
I'm still on that path.
Um,
cause I figured it out.
What does it keep going?
Keep going.
Don't be a pussy.
Keep working.
Improve objectively,
analyze your performance.
Look at what you're doing wrong.
Treat everything with respect.
Treat all of your endeavors with focus and intensity and intention.
Look at what you're doing and pay attention and do the work.
Do the Goddamn work to the writing,
to the performing.
You'll see me,
I'll do four or five sets a night in La.
I'm doing 1520 minutes,
half hour.
I'll do an hour here.
I go down the Ice House,
we'll do an hour at the ice house.
I'm doing two shows,
the Ice House tomorrow night,
and I go,
I go,
there's no excuses.
you know,
it's like,
and to me,
the way I've got it set up,
it's great.
My kids go to bed.
By the time my kids are in bed,
I leave you're out.
You know,
I say goodnight.
I tuck him in,
I'm out the door,
I'm headed to the club.
I'm home in four hours,
you know,
and when I'm,
when I'm done,
I get in front of the computer and I write,
I write,
I get up in the morning,
I see him off to school,
go back to sleep,
or I go to the gym.
I get things done,
keep moving,
got to keep moving.
I shock my job is the task.